[Music]
can i ask
where is science going to take us well i
mean is is religion doomed by the
progress of science well let's hope so
progress but the question can we
question progress for a moment let me
talk about humility first of all sure i
think it is we scientists who who show
the greater humility that the the
religious are
showing arrogance because they have a
have a a a a a line to god we do not
have that line we are amazed that
collaboration between humans in using
the scientific method of discovery the
openness of it the awareness that we
have to explore the world without
prejudice and that is in fact the case
and that
most of all that science can get things
wrong
religion can't get things
wrong science science can't get things
it does get things wrong and it's
through it's admission that it gets
things wrong that it makes progress
religion doesn't make children
i
i'd really
firstly i think again that's a
misunderstanding of religion if you go
back i mean i'm just going to talk about
islam because i can't speak for all
religions but actually the number of
debates we among scholars over you know
various issues it could be anything
debating one another changing opinions
you know
saying something that was said you know
100 years ago 50 years ago is actually
wrong and now we look at it differently
that is all there just because you don't
know it doesn't mean it's not there and
the second point i really have to make
is about price there's no progress but
well okay
can we talk about progress for just a
minute because i think i
think that to talk about progress from
where we're situated is to assume that
science and technology has been positive
for everyone can we just take a second
and acknowledge that science and
technology has not been positive for
everyone it might be positive for you
with your iphones and your nice tvs and
for me with my nice electric car and you
know living a much more comfortable
lifestyle but for many people around the
world sophisticated technology has meant
harsher forms of punishment higher ways
of
better means of keeping people who are
fleeing danger and war out of safe zones
it's meant keeping people in prisons
with more sophisticated means it means
using more sophisticated forms of
torture though you may not be aware of
them technology has also meant using
systems that control the humans that
produce the technology that we enjoy
exploiting them to every last drop so
that when the factories in china saw a
number of people who were producing
iphones committing suicide iphone turned
around and of course decided that the
best solution to overworking their
workers was to install nets um outside
the windows so that they couldn't jump
or at least they wouldn't die when they
did i'm just the idea that we're on this
relentless pursuit of progress through
technology is honestly so
western-centric there are many people
around this world for whom that
technology is actually having a very
detrimental impact specifically the kids
that are mining the stuff that we need
for our phones or the stuff that we need
for our makeup there's yeah i mean it's
it's a little bit more complex than the
idea that somehow we are beholden to
this scientific project that's bringing
us all forward through history it's not
hey
[Applause]
so anyway so
i agree with miriam that we can't
possibly have a single notion of
progress
and
indeed i would be critical of science in
the sense of saying that i think science
is a form of theology it imagines that
it's actually got to the bottom of
things and that it's described
and it and it is described how the world
is or it would be able to describe how
the world is i don't think there is a
decent uh
account of how science is capable to do
that we've not been able to develop an
account of how theory applies to the
world in such a way that we could
actually uncover some ultimate account
of what it is
but we can improve on our
our frameworks on our accounts of the
world and that is the power
of uh the enlightenment and the power of
observation and reason which was we can
have a model of the world and we can try
to improve it and that has has great
potential and in contrast to that i do
agree with peter that in general it's
the case that religion functions on the
basis of authority the authority comes
from somewhere you're not about trying
to improve it you're just trying to
use it to get an outcome that you want
and i'm very uncomfortable with with
that idea so i'm uncomfortable both with
the theology of science and with the
theology of religion instead i think we
want to be open in the way that we uh
approach the world and sense that we
need to build our models and our
accounts of it but not imagine that we
could ever get to the outcome
and in that sense have a deep humility
about what our thought and our language
can achieve but that's pessimism
i mean
look at look at the progress in
understanding that has come in the past
200 years by the application of the
scientific method we are moving forward
we are displacing old theories by new
theories which are more precise and give
us greater insight into the nature of
the world there is real progress in
science you cannot deny it
half a million people a year die from
malaria yes we can protect ourselves
from malaria through science a lot of
people in the world cannot like the
science you're talking about is the
science we're enabling people through
medicine and through
developments in molecular biology we are
seeing ways of controlling malaria yes
in theory but for whom are you then
applying might have got it and won't get
it because science is providing the way
forward and religion doesn't protect you
from malaria does it
[Music]
[Applause]
i think that's what's called a cheap
shot
so there's no shot because there's no
contradiction for me between religion
and malaria i would never advise someone
entering a malaria zone just to pray
like that's not going to happen and i
don't know anybody that would my point
to you was that when we talk about
science yes incredible developments that
are in theory capable of helping
humankind at that point what we need is
religion to say hold on this can't be
dedicated to the purpose of profit we
can't allow the values of capitalism and
individualism to harness that science
for its own ends we need to use a higher
moral framework that actually says hold
on you're just one part of a global
community any progress that you're
involved in has to progress in
everybody's world and therefore you need
to apply that and i'm not saying
everybody does it by the way just so can
i just touch on what you said for me the
highest form of arrogance is religious
people who think that they can harness
religion for their own interests it's
the worst form of arrogance and we see
it all the time it's disgusting i'm not
going to defend it just to be clear on
that but i do think that that religion
has the capacity where applied through a
stricture that is not very fashionable
today because actually most people want
just a side point that mindfulness is
the big the big trend now right
everybody's really into spirituality
within without any formal constraints on
what you have to do i'm in an adherent
of religion and i and i'm an adherent of
religion because i think spirituality
devoid of the actual demands on your ego
of fasting of praying of giving of
actual contemplation of your
responsibility vis-a-vis others is
essentially the most useful form of
spirituality within capitalism it allows
you to feel good about yourself while
you continue to consume and continue to
be part of the system and so the
religion i'm advocating for is never
going to be the one that serves itself
is one that
aims to serve a higher purpose you'd get
the same service by going to a
psychiatry department or a psychology
department in a hospital somewhere they
would help you find this sense of peace
you don't need to believe in i'd say on
that subject
speaking as a psychiatrist i know that
more and more people are coming to be
the state of profound distress and it
does seem if anything despite all the
the wonderful things that science is
dishing out to us people are getting
sadder and more frightened and one of
the questions is this where is it going
to take us in the future
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas